what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I want to be a little bit
dangerous here I want to try something
that we haven't really done before I
want to try ultimatum and the reason why
is because I think this is one of those
stories from Marvel Comics those you
guys don't know this is one of those
stories where you either love it or you
hate it there's no real middle ground
when it comes to hold too many myths
there's there's well we're gonna try
part one here but there's there's no
such thing as like I kind of liked it or
I liked parts of it there are people who
are just like I hated it like or I loved
it like that's that's that's really
about it but ultimatum is one is offense
it really comes out of the ultimate
universe now the ultimate universe in
the beginning was awesome as the years
went on it began to sort of stagnant and
it seems like one of those things work
it was just an imprint that was there
and Marvel didn't really know what to do
with it and there were some great
stories like Hickman's Ultimates was
amazing instead of the Avengers you have
the Ultimates and so really the way this
worked out to write a little bit of
backstory here the way this worked out
is the ultimate universe was the answer
to the question what would happen if
superheroes basically came into
existence right now and the Ultimate
Universe proved to be exceedingly
popular it was all really kicked off
with spider-man with x-men with
fantastic Fork that's really where it
all kind of you know began to blow up
but it was a lot more grounded and a lot
more you know tangible and in a lot more
reasonable for example the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is largely based off
the Ultimate Universe so if you really
want to read comics that tie into the
MCU that the MCU is predicated on it's
really ultimate so that's really about
it but for example in the in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we're gonna see the
x-men somewhere along the line the
reality is that how we would see the
x-men come into existence would largely
be based on the ultimate universe and
the reason why is because doing anything
else would be wildly convoluted for the
average viewer and the Ultimate Universe
the way this worked out is Nick Fury was
the first super soldier and then after
Nick Fury was Captain America and then
Captain America had basically was was
believed to have been lost Abraham
Erskine died and the Super Soldier Serum
was believed to have died with him but
in response to Captain America all these
different countries around the world
began initiating their own Super Soldier
programs Canada was trying to create a
super soldier and they had taken James
Halliday took Logan who actually I
believe was freed or fought alongside
Nick Fury in the early days but the idea
was that in trying to turn him into a
super soldier they discovered the mutant
gene and that if it was activated people
would gain powers and so much like the
Terrigen mists in the main Marvel
Universe a kind of substance was
synthesized and dispersed throughout the
planet and the result was that mutant
star
waking up that's how we got like Xavier
and Magneto and all those different guys
they weren't born with a mutant gene
that activated you to stress or due to
like puberty or anything like that
it was activated in the same way the
Inhumans were basically activated by the
terrors and myths that's the most
logical way to bring them in but the
other half of this is that there were a
lot of things that were going on we'll
explain this as we go through it but
initially what this does is it just kind
of picks up with a fantastic form this
is one of the big differences here as
Reed and Susan aren't immediately
married instead there were some
differences between the Fantastic Four
in the Ultimate Universe and the
Fantastic Four in the main Marvel
Universe most notably we picked up with
Reed Richards as a kid that really
didn't happen in the the main Marvel
Universe instead Reed Richards was
already grown up by the time the
Fantastic Four started because the
Ultimate Universe had the benefit of the
main Marvel Universe's entire
publication history starting with Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby they could kind of go
back and say well if we could do things
differently how would we do them but
we'll start with Reed Richards as a kid
and explain why he's so smart but the
idea was that as time progressed of
course the relationship began to form
and that was really it it was the idea
that all roads lead to Rome this is all
going to turn into something akin to the
main Marvel Universe as we expect to see
it it's just a little bit different in
terms of how they get there like Reed
Richards Susan storm Ben Grimm and
Johnny Storm do form the Fantastic Four
but Reed and Susan get married just by a
different set of circumstances and
that's what's happening here it's
actually Reed getting ready to pop the
question the other half of this is you
deal with Tony Stark in in Captain
America to a degree they're not
exceedingly important here there's not
that much of a difference personality
wise in terms of how you see them in the
main Marvel Universe and how you see
them in the Ultimate Universe but some
ideas that I do want to pick up on here
is a character by the name of barbara
norris she goes by the name of Valkyrie
now Valkyrie with regards to the the
Ultimate Universe is different in a lot
of ways than like the main Marvel
Universe right like Valkyrie in the main
Marvel Universe was originally just a
chick who was there but as North's
mythology really began to take hold
under Jack Kirby and various writers
especially those who came later on down
the line like Walt Simonson and expanded
on a lot of what was happening Valkyrie
became a killer or at least she was
introduced as a character and would go
on to become a character where she was
the leader of the Valkyries this group
of women that would basically rescued
the honored dead who died in battle and
escort them to Valhalla in Norse
mythology in the Ultimate Universe
because it's designed to be more
realistic that's not the case Barbara
Norris in the Ultimate Universe was just
a chick who was obsessed with
superheroes and that was it she wanted
to be one she was essentially a groupie
one
up happening is she had ran into Loki
and Loki essentially given their given
of the power of a goddess so long as she
would ally herself with Loki that
ultimately turned Koated she ended up
joining the Ultimates and basically
became a girlfriend of Thor the way
she's depicted here is designed to be
kind of like a female counterpart to
Thor but it's pretty hardcore in terms
of how she functions and in the role
that she plays something else would also
want you guys to notice is what goes on
really with like Kitty Pryde and when
Stacie
Peter Parker as well as Mary Jane Watson
The Ultimate Universe is different in a
lot of ways when it comes to the
character of Peter well I guess maybe
different isn't really the right word so
much as more modern I guess is probably
the best way to do it the chronology of
Peter still remains the same regarding
his dating life in the sense that he's
dating when Stacie he's dated Mary Jane
Watson at the moment at least I don't
never exactly I think at the time this
was going on he's dating Mary Jane but
he actually ends up going on to date
Kitty Pryde but again this is a point
where like they pretty much know his
identity I mean that's kind of the thing
with Peter is for the most part that's
one of the big differences and the main
Marvel Universe Peter Parker's identity
was hush-hush while he kept it quiet
from pretty much everyone but in this
universe people do know whose identity
now it's not a general public known
thing but that circle is larger in the
ultimate universe than it is in the main
Marvel Universe so again these are small
little tidbits small little things here
and there the other half of this is that
in the middle of this whole situation
where the various characters are kind of
going along doing their own thing the
city you know the city of New York is
suddenly met by nothing but like massive
storms and then the whole city's flooded
it's literally flooded entirely with
water and it leads to people beginning
to ask questions now much like we would
expect from the main Marvel Universe the
heroes leap into action as heroes do and
basically go about saving various people
but notice this because they're a little
more tangible and they're a little more
grounded a lot of the emphasis is really
put on themselves more so than anybody
else they do save other people but it's
really kind of like okay we got to get
out of this and like tons of people die
in the process but at this point there's
really no saving these millions of
people who have basically died when the
Incredible Hulk pops up you know where
Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk and
goes about doing his whole thing when
you have like Thor who's responding to
various situations when like Archangel
responds to these things it's really
kind of how he would expect gathering
their bearings and seeing what's going
on
now of course Susan storm does what she
can in creating a force field
it sort of blocks off a huge part of
this ocean and it's kind of cool but the
problem with this is that is believed
that Johnny Storm has basically been
lost here in the flooding of New York
City and so of course in an effort
to figure out what's going on Reed
Richards basically takes to you know
takes to the to the waters and tries to
find Johnny Storm and this brings in
Namor the Submariner
now Namor the Submariner I would say in
in the Ultimate Universe his origin or
at least how he's brought in is vastly
different from the main Marvel Universe
right in the main Marvel Universe Namor
McKenzie is the result of you know a
human and an Atlantean basically
touching naughty bit so that's really
about it I mean there's a little more to
it than that but that's the long and
short of it and this in the Ultimate
Universe I think it's actually cooler
it's basically that like the the you
know Mary Storm discovers Atlantis and
then goes to the Fantastic Four to help
her you know help her explore it they
end up discovering the sarcophagus of of
nameless Submariner and when they open
it up they release him out onto the
world and so that's when like he first
pops up whereas in the main Marvel
Universe he's been in Atlantis for a
long time he fought alongside Captain
America and the invaders he's been part
of the superhero community for a while
and so it works because again we're name
were the Submariner was the first mutant
hybrid more or less in the Ultimate
Universe it's designed to kind of set
things back and incorrect things a
little bit so again as the ruler of the
Seas the immediate response of really of
Reed Richards due to like the aggression
that Namor has in terms of like do not
come to my ocean you know do not poison
poison where I live is that Reed
believes that name was the one that set
all this off and that's one of the big
similarities is that name of the
Submariner much like Aquaman who came
after him much like these sea dwelling
kings in the various comic comic book
mythos the idea is that if there is like
a massive ocean wide event then it had
to have been named or who allowed it to
happen now of course Reed Richards is
able to subdue name work ultimately ends
up knocking him out but then Reed asked
the question if neighbor was not the
person who was responsible for this than
who was now the initial indication of
everybody who was reading this at the
time was well of course it was dr. doom
why wouldn't it be dr. doom he's always
plotting world domination and this is
something dr. doom would do you know
because remember when it comes to this
thing while you do have various
characters who are out there that are
indicative of like the main Marvel
Universe that draw on the main Marvel
Universe they're not usually on the same
scale and because dr. doom I would argue
is probably one of the most credible
threats in Marvel Comics in the Ultimate
Universe that's where a lot of people's
thoughts resided and the way the Jeff
Logan company nip this in the bud is
they pick up in Latvia and what isn't
happening here is like dr. doom ins have
realized in the like one the place is
freezing to various people are frozen
over in 3 when he gets out
Latveria the whole city the whole town
is frozen over the whole place has been
completely frozen solid and so what we
end up doing here is picking up with the
x-men themselves and Charles Xavier and
the reason for this is because Xavier
knows everything that's going on and so
where you have like Wolverine who
responds Cyclops so on and so forth
Xavier actually sends out a telepathic
SOS to all the Ultimates to the varying
of The Ultimates of Fantastic Four -
more or less the entire superhero
community and Marvel in the Ultimate
Universe and says I know who did this
and I know why you have to go and find
him and you have to stop him and that's
when we end up finding out then not only
does magneto half Thor's hammer
but magneto was the one who set all this
in motion he's the one that has
basically instigated all this now I'm
waiting into the really waiting to the
interview list the reason why is because
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch the kids
of magneto were killed in Ultimates 3
there was the Ultron rebellion which I
think led to the death of Scarlet Witch
and then Quicksilver I believe was
killed by Hawkeye but the idea is that
like his kids have basically died and
that set magneto on a warpath now this
was Marvel's way of trying to blend like
the traditional magneto mythos with like
the ultimate universe and the reason why
is because in in the main Marvel
Universe Magneto's mythos has always
been that like he wants to basically
allow mutants to overcome humanity and
this has been done in like a wide array
of different ways right like I mean
there was asteroid aim and Avalon when
the x-men invaded magneto ship tried to
stop him and then the humans launched
nukes at magneto and he issued a blanket
EMP across the world and shut everything
down like there's been a multitude of
instances where he's trying to like
liberate quote/unquote mutant kind where
he's like try to lead rebellions against
the entirety of humanity where he's had
mutants like leave the planet Earth for
safety away from humans and this
Magneto's a little bit different here
but this is kind of grabbing those
elements and rolling them in and
bringing them over and saying even if
it's by a different means even if it's
because of like Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver and it's like basically
something as baseline as vengeance the
idea is that like Magneto's trying to
attack the world like he's trying to
conquer the world more or less so it
still falls into the same vein but it
also still works but what this means is
that Magneto's the one that's instigated
all of this and it's basically magneto
against the entirety of the Marvel
Universe but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and let me know down in
the comments section because again this
is really more of a test so let me know
down in the comments section if you guys
want to see actually if you guys want to
see more of this just drop likes I guess
is the best way to do it at least it
likes to let me know
is usually more people will drop a like
than they will will leave comments
because most people don't really care
enough to put comments uh so just drop
it like if you really want to see more
of this and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]